Love, as they say, is in the air.
And Hollywood has made trillions of dollars
because of it.
There’s just something about watching two
people become completely obsessed with each
other that audiences find endlessly satisfying.
But we aren’t the only ones who feel it,
and sometimes the chemistry on screen appears
real because it is.
These are 10 Famous Actors Who Hooked Up With
Their Co-stars.
Ryan Gosling and Eva Mendes, The Place Beyond
the Pines
In 2012’s The Place Beyond The Pines, the
chemistry between Ryan Gosling and Eva Mendes
is so prevalent, it’s bound to steam up
the inside of your screen.
Director Derek Cianfrance tells the gritty
story of a man dead set on providing for his
family.
After learning about the birth of his son,
Gosling quits the carnival and gets himself
a big boy job as a bank robber.
It just so happens he’s one hell of a driver
so it was the natural choice.
In addition to the movie, Gosling and Mendes
are a couple in real life, and even have two
kids.
Heath Ledger and Michelle Williams, Brokeback
Mountain
Brokeback Mountain did a lot of things for
cinema, and it focused viewers attention on
the topic of love.
The cast is stacked with talented young actors,
and because director Ang Lee is behind the
camera, it’s also beautiful.
The movie won three Oscars, and three of the
lead actors, including Heath Ledger and Michelle
Williams, were nominated for their work in
it.
This film is where the two actors began their
relationship.The couple were together from
2004 to 2007, and their daughter Matilda was
born in 2005.
Kit Harrington and Rose Leslie, Game of Thrones
John Snow has been causing quite a stir these
days, and is quickly turning into the most
talked about character in Game of Thrones.
And if you’re keeping up with the show,
you know it’s for a good reason.
But more than a few fans lost their collective
shit when his lady-love, Ygritte, was killed
off by the ruthless and cold-hearted George
R.R. Martin- a man who is famous for destroying
everything you love.
There’s one thing he can’t kill though,
and that’s love.
Kit Harrington and Rose Leslie have been dating
for real, on and off, since meeting on set.
Tom Cruise and Nicole Kidman, Days of Thunder
Tom Cruise may be known for his couch-jumping,
Oprah stunt in which he loudly declared his
love for Katie Holmes.
But back in 1990 it was love at first sight
between him and leading lady Nicole Kidman.
The two met while filming Days of Thunder,
in which Cruise plays a young stock car driver
with a big dream.
And Kidman is a girl with some big hair.
The two fell head over heels and got married
that same year.
They were a couple until 2001, and even did
a few more movies together along the way.
Andrew Garfield and Emma Stone, The Amazing
Spider-Man
When Andrew Garfield described meeting Emma
Stone for the first time in 2011, he said
it was “like diving into whitewater rapids
and having no desire to hang on to the side”.
Which is just about the cutest thing we’ve
ever heard.
The two began dating while working on The
Amazing Spider-Man, and stayed together for
four years.
It’s a good thing the two liked each other,
since the movie had a pretty intense promotional
schedule that saw them spending every single
day in close proximity for months.
And despite their break up in 2015, they remain
friends.
Channing Tatum and Jenna Dewan, Step Up
Before he was Magic Mike, Channing Tatum was
dancing up a storm in a little movie called
Step Up.
In the wake of some poor decisions, his character
Tyler ends up at a performing arts school.
A troublemaker with a checkered past and a
passion for dance, Tyler soon finds himself
enamored with a student named Nora.
And just as Tyler had a thing for Nora, Tatum
was falling in love for real with the girl
playing her; Jenna Dewan.
But you might know her as Jenna Dewan Tatum.
The two have been together for ten years,
and married in 2013.
There are entire blogs dedicated to the idea
of “relationship goals”, and these two
always make the list.
Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie, Mr. and Mrs.
Smith
Brangelina is a certified Hollywood power-couple,
but it hasn’t always been rainbows and sunshine.
The tale of Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie’s
romance actually started off a little rocky.
The actors met while working on the film Mr.
and Mrs. Smith, and the rumor mill began to
churn.
Pitt was in a relationship with Jennifer Aniston
at the time, and it didn’t take long for
rumblings of infidelity to start.
Shortly after the actor separated from Aniston,
he began a relationship with his Mr. and Mrs.
Smith co-star, which was huge news at the
time.
The couple is now known for their human rights
advocacy work, have six children, and got
married in 2014.
Ryan Reynolds and Blake Lively, Green Lantern
Opening to largely negative reviews, 2011’s
Green Lantern was panned by audiences for
its liberal use of CGI.
Especially when it came to the titular character’s
suit.
But all was not lost.
And one really great thing happened as a result:
the real life romance of Blake Lively and
Ryan Reynolds.
Sure, there was some time in between those
events, but it’s the end result we’re
interested in.
Both on screen and off, the two make a really
great team.
Which is a good thing, since the two had their
first child in December of 2014.
Justin Theroux and Jennifer Aniston, Wanderlust
For a while there, Jennifer Aniston could
not catch a break.
All eyes have seemingly been on her romantic
life since Friends took over television in
the nineties.
And the actress has gone through more public
breakups than anyone should ever have to endure.
After her divorce from Brad Pitt in 2005,
the airwaves exploded with controversy.
For a long time, everyone had an opinion on
who the starlet should (and should not) be
dating.
But after meeting Justin Theroux, the two
became fast friends.
And, after a few years of knowing each other,
the two were married in 2015.
Dax Shepard and Kristen Bell
When two genuinely nice people get together,
we can’t help but cheer.
And in 2007 Dax Shepard found Kristen Bell.
The two hilarious blondes met and fell in
love, despite viewing themselves as complete
opposites.
But their adoration for one another is so
obvious, especially on the red carpet.
They’re always laughing, and are constantly
gushing about each other in interviews.
Shepard and Bell are that couple who are so
cute, it physically hurts.
Technically they didn’t meet on set, but
they have worked together on more than one
occasion.
The couple have two kids, and got married
in 2013.
What do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite actors who
hooked up with their co-stars?
Tell us about them in the comments, and subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more of our behind
the scenes videos.